let's get back to discord and hear from
more of you for the first time in 2022
you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to
pablo from albuquerque new mexico pablo
you're on the air
okay um
so uh i was calling in um
can you hear me yes i can what's your
what's on your mind today sorry about
that
um
uh i was calling uh because you know how
it's fairly common now for uh
republicans to say that they're
a little l uh libertarian
um as a way of kind of distancing
themselves from like a more
well libertarians from the libertarian
party yeah
yeah
um
do you think that would be something
that
uh democrats could do as a way of like
sort of
like let's say saying
oh yeah i'm uh
you know
uh
like i'm trying to figure out how
exactly to phrase it like uh the bull
moose party was a fairly progressive
party
uh so
would there be a way that people could
be like oh yes uh i'm a small d democrat
as a way of kind of
um
yeah i don't think so because the
difference is that when people talk
about being democrats i know that
there's this idea of just i'm for
democracy but that's it doesn't have the
same meaning like for example i as a
progressive
tend to be what you might call small l
libertarian on a lot of different issues
and that my preference is if there's not
a good reason for government to be
involved i don't need government
involved however i draw that line very
differently than right-wing libertarians
okay so so it there's some sort of
coherence there
small d democrat doesn't really make
sense because it's sort of a confusing
term
i think that there's probably some other
way to describe being i mean listen when
i say
i am a libertarian leaning progressive
uh or sometimes i even say i'm an
anti-authoritarian progressive because
there are kind of revolutionary leftists
that are much more authoritarian i feel
like i'm not using partisan terms to
describe things but um i don't know i i
think that uh i think i don't know that
small d democrat really makes sense to
be totally frank with you
no i i understand i'm just again you
know just thinking about you're thinking
out loud i love it i love it yeah
um all right i think that's it all right
thanks so much uh pablo from albuquerque
new mexico great to hear from you a lot
of very good questions today